die sogenannten denisova menschen sind
für fachleute ein großes rätsel wie
sahen diese urmenschen aus sie sich vor
rund 800.000 jahren von der stammes
linie des modernen menschen abgespaltet
haben fest steht nur diese
schwestergruppe der neandertaler hat
sich im erbgut vieler heute lebender
populationen verewigt beispielsweise im
genom der asiaten und der ur australier
einem internationalen forschungsteam ist
es jetzt endlich gelungen die anatomie
dieser urmenschen so rekonstruieren und
das einzig und allein durch die analyse
eines fingerknochen und von ein paar
zehen und es gibt noch eine verblüffende
erkenntnis krieg zum science fiction
hier gibt es täglich spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur dann verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen der
denisova mensch ist fachleuten erst seit
einigen jahren bekannt denn fossilien
dieser urmenschen wurden erstmalig im
jahr 2008 entdeckt damals fand ein
russisches forschungsteam zähne und das
fragment eines fingerknochen in
südsibirien im mai diesen jahres 2009 10
kamen dann ein weiterer spektakulärer
fund dazu ein weiteres fossil eines
denisova-menschen wurde nämlich zum
ersten mal außerhalb von sibirien
aufgespürt und zwar in einer höhle in
tibet hierbei handelte es sich um einen
gut erhaltenen unterkiefer fachleute
werden diesen fund als beleg dafür dass
die rätselhafte hominiden auch in
ostasien verbreitet waren anders als die
neandertaler die vor allem in west asien
und europa verbreitet waren zogen die
denisova menschen wohl durch ostasien es
handelt sich um eine weit entfernte
schwestergruppe der neandertaler doch
die denisova menschen lebt
möglicherweise sogar noch vor etwa
40.000 jahren im zentralasiatischen
altay gebirge doch die wenigen funde
verraten nicht viel über sie bekannt ist
nur dass sie sich vor rund 800.000
jahren von der stammes linie des
modernen menschen abgespaltet hatten
diese menschen form war damals höchst
wahrscheinlich weit verbreitet denn die
spuren von denisova dna die sind noch
heute im erbgut von populationen
vorhanden sie finden sich beispielsweise
im genom von australien
also uhr australien asiaten und
melanesien eingehen das wahrscheinlich
von den denisova-menschen stammt
verleiht den tibetern ihre
höhenanpassung doch vor allem die
anatomie dieser
viele menschen gibt der fachwelt große
rätsel auf bis jetzt denn nun hat ein
forschungsteam detaillierte dna analysen
durchgeführt um das aussehen der
denisova menschen zu rekonstruieren als
basis diente die die dna aus den bereits
aufgesprühten zähnen und aus dem
fingerknochen doch zu der gewöhnlichen
dna analyse wurden so genannte
epigenetische indikatoren hinzugezogen
dabei handelt es sich um chemische
anhänge der dna diese spielen
tatsächlich eine entscheidende rolle bei
der genaktivität und bei der umsetzung
der genetischen bauanleitungen so konnte
eine sogenannte methylon karte erstellt
werden diese enthält informationen
darüber wie sogenannte methylgruppen an
das erbgut angelagert werden und genau
dabei handelt es sich um die eben
erwähnten dna anhänge die entscheiden
wie stark ein gen abgelesen wird und in
welchem ausmaß ist somit auch das
aussehen einer art beeinflusst dazu der
forscher david beckham der an der studie
beteiligt war
dadurch erhielten wir eine vorstellung
davon welche teile des skeletts durch
diese epigenetische regulation betroffen
sind und in welche richtung diese
skelettteile sich dadurch verändert
beispielsweise ein längerer oder
kürzerer oberschenkelknochen das
ergebnis verglichen die fachleute dann
mit dem erbgut der modernen menschen und
mit dem der neandertaler konkret sind es
56 anatomische eigenschaften durch die
sich die denisova menschen von denen der
der taler oder des modernen menschen
unterscheiden 34 davon beziehen sich
allein auf den schädel
dieses ergebnis ermöglicht es dem
forschungsteam das gesicht und den
körperbau der urmenschen zu
rekonstruieren das zeigt ganz deutlich
dass die denisova menschen wohl einen
breiteren schädel als die neandertaler
und dem modernen menschen hatten ihr
becken war breiter als das des modernen
menschen und das gesicht stand hervor
ähnlich wie beim neandertaler die
rekonstruktion der jungen denisova frau
zeigt auch dass ihr zahn bogen
verlängert ist sie ein längliches
gesicht hat und eine fliehende stirn
auch das enge dem neandertaler als
einzigartiges charakteristikum der
denisova menschen fällt das wirklich
breite gesicht auf und der lange kiefer
bogen das ergebnis ist eine premiere für
die fachwelt dazu der genetiker lian
kaml der an der studie beteiligt war
gebieten die erste rekonstruktion der
anatomie des skeletts von delhi sofa
urmenschen in vielen punkten in ähneln
denen sowohl menschen denen er an lagern
in manchen eigenschaften erinnern sie
uns und den anderen sind sie einzigartig
eine kleine einschränkung ist an dieser
stelle aber wichtig dass aktuelle
studien ergebnis beruht auf dem
erbmaterial eines einzelnen individuums
das bedeutet im klartext dass die
äußeren merkmale somit nicht unbedingt
für alle denisova menschen gelten müssen
erst die analyse weiterer fossilien
funde kann zeigen ob es sich hier
tatsächlich um art spezifische
eigenheiten handelt eine weitere
aktuelle studie hat übrigens auch das
erbgut der denisova menschen im visier
gehabt und ein weiteres spannendes
ergebnis zu tage gebracht demnach
könnten die urmenschen dem modernen
menschen eine bessere immunabwehr
beschert haben laut der aktuellen nature
studie ist dem modernen menschen eine
genvariante dieser menschen zu finden
die entzündungsreaktion unterstützt also
unsere abwehr von entzündung neue studie
bislang unbekannte neandertaler
population entdeckt dieses video
anklicken anschauen und klicks um
science-fiction abonnieren bis dann
bleibt dran